the the the the Revolution and the
Takeover is now in an intellectual one
yeah a lot of the time strength doesn't
it doesn't matter in that situation what
matters is how how much you can out
think the opponent and so a lot of the
time now in these in these days and
times the the week and our governing the
strong because and I say that on on
another front where if your feelings get
hurt for instance
we can now cancel you and we can now
make new laws to make our feelings not
get hurt so the weak are now governing
the strong so the strong say things like
Andrew take like Kevin Samuels to
um you know to cut through the the
nonsense like you said but if somebody's
feelings get hurt you understand who's
really in power
well yeah and you've just got to look at
what happened obviously with with the
tights although you know obviously I'm
sure he'll be he'll be fine he'll be
fine but you know it's a very
interesting example isn't it of how
everybody just sort of like they just
all of his socials just went down like
dominoes because of feelings
yeah and that's the thing and even when
I was at carnival like the the visceral
reaction I got from women like
interviewing them and I said what do you
think of Andrew Tate and they're
immediately like and I'm like what does
he say that's that bad yeah like okay
men don't like old women like who cares
I don't think it's anything he says that
is bad it's kind of like um with
um Kevin Samuels how he when I first
before I first watched his videos I'd be
like oh Kevin blah blah blah bad things
about black women blah blah blah when I
watched I was like he's actually okay
the truth and so I think when it comes
to women
when it comes to women and
not just women but mainly in this
conversation when something is brought
against them they don't take the time to
listen and look into what it is this
person is saying is instantly like you
said something against women we're going
to try to get you off as quickly as
possible instead of sitting down
listening to what he's saying taking the
bits that are like okay maybe that's
true and other bits be like Ah that's
not true and taking it in me and being
like how can I better myself from this
conversation that this man had even
though his approach may not be something
that I like to hear but what his words
are saying is something that I may need
to hear that's what it is I feel like
women
feel a lot more by the way men say
things but going down to the factual
things we don't really take it in as you
said like it's just based on as you said
one word and we're just like no that was
rude but it's just like you have to take
it in a bit more but it depends on
maturity but that's why I said the week
the week now governed the strong because
only the weak yet yeah you know I mean
their feelings get hurt and then they
govern the strong and they say oh you're
not allowed to say that now now there's
no more strong people because the wheat
got offended yeah but we were talking
about this the other the other day or
that fresh and fit show and I was the
it came up like what did he actually get
canceled for and I can't even I mean
maybe somebody can answer but I can't
think specifically what he got canceled
for really it was just he got canceled
just for being Andrew Tate really and
like one you know social media company
banned him then the next one and then
they're probably sitting there in their
boardroom thinking oh God we've got to
do something about this guy and then so
the next one goes down and it was like
that wasn't it it wasn't I don't think
it was like a specific like you know
there was a certain sentence or yeah
I don't think there was anything
specific that he got canceled for
um zubi was a guess and I think he was a
flying a little bit too close to the Sun
in some subject areas and exposing
certain areas of the world and they were
like gotta cut them off yeah yeah yeah
you know I only came into
um aware of Andrew tape because he was
getting banned obviously I've seen him
around
um on the internet but I never really
paid attention to it yeah until people
started oh this guy's got banana then I
started looking into it and I'm like
listening to some of the things he's
saying I was like like he said I
couldn't quite pinpoint yeah what it was
but then then if you dig a deeper
they'll be like oh he's a
um he's like sex trafficking he's a sex
trafficker and things like that and I'm
one of those people I take what people
say on the internet with a Pinter so
especially if a collective of people are
saying it together but then you hear him
explain it and then he's like I've never
been arrested for it oh there's no
charges for it and things of this nature
then I started to realize that you're
not actually giving real evidence to why
you want to ban them like you said just
because do you think his masculinity is
the thing that's that's that scared
people well maybe but just to play
devil's advocate here for a second is
this actually an attack on masculinity
using him as an example but you know we
can broad broaden it out or is it just
basically all these companies want to
make money and they're all protecting
their bottom line and they're protecting
their bottom line because they're like
oh if we if people are getting offended
because we're allowing this dude to be
on our Channel then we're going to lose
money we're going to lose subscribers
we're gonna lose our Revenue whatever
so it's not from the Takeover Lord's
point of view it may not necessarily be
some so much like oh he's toxically
masculine I hate that that stuff it it
could it just be like oh damn we don't
want to lose cash so let's be careful
you see what I'm saying but could I do I
I think it may be both to some degree
and I think
um that may be a byproduct of the attack
on masculinity if that makes sense so
yeah so getting rid of him is a
byproduct of there being an attack on
masculinity because it's like he's too
masculine people are getting offended so
let's so let's get rid of him so for me
I feel like you know
um if you look at masculinity within
what we're sold in the media you know
when it comes to fatherhood and if you
look at the Simpsons you look at Family
Guy you look at all of these shows this
the fathers and the men in there are
bumbling idiots yes you know what I mean
and so when we get sold what masculinity
is we get sold it to us like men are
kind of stupid and yeah women are the
Smart Ones you know yeah and to adverts
as well are really bad for that if you
watch TV adverts like supermarkets and
DIY stores and stuff like that it's
always the stupid stupid husband you
know dumb husband yeah yeah do you think
if Andrew Tate was a woman used to be on
the internet oh yeah for sure I mean
we'll see they call me Andrea Kate
I don't think they took away my Tic Tac
though so maybe not but if a woman was
delivering in the same tone Andrew Tate
would take delivering it do you think
she would get
um taken off I don't I don't think so no
I don't know I think I think there's a
double it'll be interesting to see I
think so because like I said I keep I
think I generally believe is an attack
on Truth more than masculinity I didn't
and I just that's why I would like to
see if there's a woman who delivers it
the same way as Andrew Tate I tell you
why not I tell you I don't think so the
other day um literally last week I
watched a video of a female male rapper
with a song called Murder on my mind and
she was talking about aborting her child
and the whole song was about how she's
going down to Planned Parenthood and
she's forgotten to take her plan B and
she's got murder on her mind and she's
gonna take and she's gonna get rid of
her child and that was trending on yeah
exactly on the internet she never got
canceled and so if you can be that
vulgar as a woman and you can be that to
in my personal point of view crazy
and that let's say I don't know it's not
misogyny it's not misandrist but it's
really anti-child and anti-family is she
popular though who is it
um you know we could actually search it
now you can just put murder on my mind
right with Andrew Tate is a lot more
because there's a lot more people
watching it you know if people a lot
more people are watching it they're
going to want to cancel her but you know
like if the person is not too popular no
one really knows her what about cardi B
she drugged a man she drugged him out
yeah
about it quick really guys
um we just hit 400.
400 guys
400k 400k that's like basically half a
million
biggest biggest Super Chat decides what
we do for half a million 500 the cap
yeah what we're gonna do for half a
minute yeah what 24 hour live stream no
no no no
yeah everyone here is nothing eight
hours almost eight hours of that 48
Hours yeah the 24 hour live stream was
horrible that was crazy but anyway let's
get back
um if I can we say something no no no
gorgeous no uh I was just gonna say that
I think I agreeing with you that I think
that
um
attack on masculinity is also profitable
nowadays right the more the more you can
side it with
the um the feminist movement and talk
down about men as much as possible the
more
it's popular to do nowadays and you just
said oh what the the female rapper even
if she was big and out there
I don't think she would I don't think
she would get canceled at all because
that's something that
it's liberating for women to have the
opportunity now that it's different in
the states the laws are different in the
states for abortion it's like oh yeah
you have the freedom to go do that now
so I don't think that she would ever
even if she was a big well-known artist
I don't think she would get canceled
because of that
um do you guys have an idea if we go
around what I'm gonna ask what is a
masculine man to you as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible